the UN is now considering a ban on gay
conversion so we've got some info on gay
conversion for you the UN Committee
Against Torture has filed a shadow
report on the subject the shadow report
focuses on the US and urges every state
to adopt legislation or regulations
prohibiting state licensed professionals
from attempting to change a minors
sexual orientation or gender identity
I'm going to tell you a little bit more
about what's going on in America but
first if the NCLR and its allies are
successful in having the UN panel
declare that anti-gay therapy is torture
it could have implications for the US
and other countries as signatories of
the Convention Against Torture and other
cruel inhuman or degrading treatment or
punishment treaty it's possible that
such nations could be obliged as a
matter of international law not to allow
the practice of sexual orientation
change efforts or prosecute individuals
that perform it so interestingly here
now first off there's a lot of questions
as to whether the UN can actually do
anything and they pass all these
resolutions and then not much changes
they've got awful countries on human
rights boards and all kinds of nonsense
that we talk a lot about but in the
United States right now 48 of our states
still allow gay conversion therapy
Michele Bachmann Michele Bachmann's
husband was a gay conversion therapy
Whitney do you have any jokes on that
one but when I when I saw this it was
making me think that maybe this is more
important for Americans to stand up then
even gay marriage at this point because
the gay marriage thing is happened like
basically now there's gonna be a mess in
Florida because of the new governor and
Texas it's gonna take a while
you're Florida yeah yeah but it's pretty
much happened and if you live in America
and you really want to marry a saint the
person of the same sex you can go to a
place and be treated equally by the law
but that this is much more damaging
because it's what it's doing to young
people right people realize is that this
is essentially the equivalent of you
know taking an african-american kid
putting them in a camp and telling them
that they need to become white by the
time they leave yeah it it people need
to realize that this is not something
that is by choice you are born this way
and and that's and that's what it is
it's the equivalent of changing race or
anything like that it's it can't be done
yeah so therefore it is torture because
it's impossible to create another and
it's also torture because I mean look at
the methods that they use for their
electroshock therapy so they literally
show that person so if it's if it's a
gay male they show that person gay porn
and then electrocute them so that
eventually give them drugs or something
to make them nauseous so that they're
actually throwing up and physically ill
at the sight of these images and then of
course they'll do the opposite where
they show them you know heterosexual
things and make them happy or feel good
or you know yeah touch them and
appropriately you know so it's just that
is torture so Mexico seems like it
totally blurred cross crosses blurred
lines between like you know mala station
and weirdness that goes on with that
right well it's also like all these
can't right these camps where they do
this and it's like these adults that are
obviously closeted and they're like how
do you how do you get past your gay
feelings you have to cuddle with me for
an hour while you tell me about your
sexual fantasies I mean really
disgusting stuff but what does it say
though about in America because this
seems to me like this would be going on
in the rest of the world but it's still
happening here how would we not we got
the gay marriage thing going okay great
but how do we leave this like severely
damaging psychological thing in place I
mean that's that's a good question I I
don't know like it baffles me that that
is still going on today I mean it's
still going on because of the fact that
the people that are getting sent to
these camps are children and people that
are not spoken for you know gate with
gay marriage we're adults were outspoken
we have opinions we're taking action
these are kids that don't have an outlet
they don't have somebody to turn to they
don't have help yeah that's an
interesting point so there's something
like not sexy about it I don't know
that's a bad word I suppose but like
something about like gay marriage you
can see adults there's something there's
a way to frame it that seems mature as I
am this it's so
gross actually Bokan I mean just for
being an unknown thing you know these
conversion camps I think the the people
that know about it are the parents that
want to put their kids in it you know
it's not something that's really
discussed outside of that because you
know people those people are adults and
they're embracing their sexuality and
they're working towards gay marriage but
they're forgetting about you know the
youth that are getting put into these
these action that's supposed to come in
because this is child abuse you know
they should not have the ability to do
that to their children so obviously the
problem lies with the government not
having stricter regulations on this I
can't believe they're still allowing it
but also we need to focus on the parents
and the mentality that goes behind
creating this type of thing to begin
with yeah so there's definitely been a
theme to this show between government
and religion and saying but this must be
one of those things that drives you
particularly crazy right because the the
conversion people most of this I would
venture to say that probably 95 percent
of it is based in religion somehow or
across the board it's all the religions
I know everybody wants to pick a
religion sire you hate that religion all
the religions do this awful conversion
[ __ ] so this must be something that
particularly drives you nuts because it
shows how the government and religion
are still so intertwined it's not the
separation of church and state that
there needs to be and it's just an yet
another example of how religion poisons
everything